[Music]
Got a Friend in Me
You've Got a Friend in Me
Peter Murgatroyd and Maxim schmierkovsky
welcome a new addition to their growing
family it's a great feeling check out
this sweet moment of the couple
surprising their six-year-old son shy
with his new furry best friend when the
road
rough ahead in your miles and miles from
your nice warm bed
you just remember what your past
and Max write in the caption meet our
newest family member Hachi smirkovsky
they say the pub has already brought so
much joy into their lives and shy is
obsessed we probably bit off more than
we can chew with another actual human
arriving soon but hey there is never a
perfect time right he was looking at my
stomach he's like Mommy you've got a
baby in there and I was like
I looked at him I was like we do Peta
and Max revealed in January they're
expecting baby number two in June now it
finally happened for us and you know shy
can finally get that sibling that I've
wanted to give him but their journey to
get there hasn't been easy Max and Peta
have been open about their challenges
conceiving including their attempts with
IVF I shouldn't be chatting it into the
side I shall be doing it
foreign
success it's done it's done
guys I know there's no promises
I know that this is you know a risk a
gamble we don't know what's going to
happen but
I think this is the most excited I've
been in
a very long time I honestly you know you
hear the horror stories about it you
know marriage is breaking up all that
stuff you know it's it's
uh pretty dramatic but um I it hasn't
gone there it is skeptic to the openness
of it and how open do we want to be and
now I realize that there is the reason
why people do struggle with it is
because it's such a taboo to talk but
after two years a constant struggle and
heartache three miscarriages and a
failed Embryo transfer they have a
healthy bun in the oven there were
moments when when it was devastating and
then it turned out to be beautiful so
you know life is incredible it's uh it's
just a lot of up and down you know and
you got to be ready for it and Max and
Peta have been dancing with joy
bump in
[Music]
I just want all of the ladies and
couples that are going through this
journey
um and and the ups and downs of it are
wild uh there is a light at the end of
it just just be patient uh I know it
sounds rough to say but
it'll it'll it'll it'll all be good
[Music]